so far succeeding in limiting our access
to exercise our constitutional right
it's not a constitution raised by the
way but these are the same people who
don't believe in the constitutional
right to keep and bear arms which
actually is a constitutional right right
next to number one which includes
freedom of speech which you also don't
believe in you're stepping over rights
to grab ones that don't exist like free
speech let's move that over here right
to bear arms I don't really like it
because David hog wasn't a Michael Moore
film 14th Amendment's right to privacy
therefore you get an abortion at 32
weeks says Elizabeth Warren that's what
I'm pretty confident on this isn't
running for two days now and of course
Georgia and Alabama there's been so so
much misinformation out there it really
has been driving me nuts I don't just
want to say oh it's driving me crazy
it's wrong I want to let you know as to
why it's incorrect and I want to know
what I guess intellectual fallacies
you've seen most out there so here a
couple of claims that I've seen most one
of them let's go right off the bat
they've been claiming everywhere
by the way and aoc kind of claimed it
but it was people said they
misinterpreted her tweet I don't know
I'll give it water line
you don't need a OC on this one because
everyone else has been saying that these
laws constitute jailing women for murder
if a Georgia resident plans to travel
elsewhere to obtain an abortion when she
comes back she could face 10 years
imprisonment don't you meaning abortion
without once a tan and one said party
yeah whom are you going to imprison
every woman who's had a fertilized egg
pass through her no you just I don't
know mr. mechanical engineer guy
[Laughter]
specifically because they've kind of
thrown in Georgia and Alabama yeah okay
they both mixed specifically criminalize
the act of performing the abortion
outside of the listed parameters exact
they very clearly expressed banning the
or the it's the person is performing the
abortion exactly their subsequent claim
that the Georgia Billy claim has loose
language that could maybe lead to the
prosecution of women who take an
abortion pill or who travel to other
states or who even miscarry this is one
we've been hearing a lot you miscarriage
under this these lots stupid is that
well here's the thing and I've been
doing a lot of research since 4:00 in
the morning they've only been
who recorded incidents of woman being
charged with any kind of crime
associated with her abortion okay one
was in 1911 and one was in 1922
throughout the less I'm wrong about this
throughout the entire history of an
angel the American Western law only one
woman was ever charged with the crime of
self abortion that specific crime 1599
you have to go back one 1500s no woman
ever in the history of modern Western
law as far as I know let me offer has
been charged with a crime for
miscarrying yes
I've not seen it am I do you know if it
again 50 99 one time what was well you
know what maybe before roe v-- wade
people weren't being locked in the
slammer because they were taking a pill
that's not what what's happening hit the
notifications else women Westerners love
that hot bookmark the page cuz
notification bells don't mean a whole
lot if you're subscribed not endorsed
join mug club and iTunes leave a review
rating there yeah here's another thing
to the people been saying then it's just
right-wing extremism and then it's
completely unprecedented that's actually
from so on that all evangelize don't try
to put you in jail for misc this
actually this is something I think
people don't understand we have pretty
liberal laws regarding abortion the
majority of European countries actually
have abortion bans after 12 weeks and a
lot of them require waiting period after
consulting with a doctor either at least
it's intellectually consistent for these
people who say abortion period on demand
no questions asked because it's may
either it's a tragedy or why should it
be rare exactly who cares why would you
want it to be does anyone want pap
smears to be rare no no they want doctor
checkups to be rare no they don't want
people removing swollen tonsils to be
red no so I don't even it's a finding or
who cares whether it's rare so I'm glad
that at least right now we're having
this conversation openly and honestly
another claim that you for this is a big
fear mongering claim from the left and
it's not entirely by the way unfounded
that this is going to 100% lead to the
overturning of roe v-- wade
setting up a potential showdown in the
highest court of the land unless new
abortion law the strictest in our
country is setting up a direct challenge
to Roe vs. Wade
Donald Trump said in the third debate
with Hillary Clinton oh if I get two or
more appointments to the Supreme Court
automatically that's the word he used
automatically row v Wade will be
overturned and I think the president was
exactly right
row v without according to cabin on and
every woman in Alabama who gets pregnant
is gonna be forced to give birth soon
okay so you think oh no people would
like the seat overturn yeah probably a
lot now about well we don't fact yes a
lot in Alabama that's a separate issue
from the argument this is a there's a
few common misconceptions about roe v--
wade and what would happen if it were
overturned yeah okay all states place
restrictions or most states place
restrictions regulations and abortions
outside of the federal purview Texas
they wanted a ban abortion after 20
weeks yeah which Elizabeth Warren
famously opposed because she's morally
everyone has the hell they're willing to
die on what's yours the hill littered
with dead babies yeah it's the dying
hill that's why I thought it was the
most appropriate the hill I want to dine
is the dying Hill Colorado may be 34
weeks Virginia 25 weeks and these laws
often make it bill you probably know
about this half-asian bill they make it
to higher courts yes so there's truth to
that yeah they do I mean the the the
case itself allows to have different
restrictions based on the trimesters
that was the kind of fundamental right
no practical application of it and so we
have always since Roe vs. Wade had
limitations and really again I think who
goes back to your point which is where
if you really do think it's as easy as
clipping a nail and it's as is you know
morally irrelevant as clipping a
fingernail then you should just be
you're probably more consistent to just
say it should be allowed always right
and in these other states essentially to
say oh that Roe versus Wade may be
challenged well Roe vs. Wade was a is a
very complex opinion that sets different
types of restrictions at different time
masters and it also has a certain basis
in the Fourteenth Amendment the right to
privacy and so you can you can maybe
parse can you explain that because
doesn't make a lot of people don't know
they think that roe v wade says there's
a constitutional right to abortion and
they think there in the Constitution
there's some interpreted right to
abortion so what what the Fourteenth
Amendment which was the basis of the
opinion is the saying that yes here you
have the Constitution through the Bill
of Rights which says or rather through
an amendment it wasn't in the Bill of
Rights but to say you can have a right
of privacy which that word
actually there but it's interpreted as
one of the rights that are broadly
enumerated in the 14th amendment and
then from that derivative right right to
privacy you then have a defer the
derivative sub derivative right that
says that your body and being able to
are going to do with your body so and I
think intellectually like in a very high
level a lot of people wouldn't
understand I mean there's a lot of you
know libertarian fans of the show who
would say your right to privacy allows
you to put in your body whatever you
want or to be able to do with your body
whatever you want so it's not like that
entire spectrum of our you know and but
I think that's a valid argument I think
that libertarians you say not only do I
think possibly legal but I think someone
should be able to shoot heroin in the
house if they want to I think it's very
hard to argue against that
constitutionally and it's a compelling
argument and but the difference becomes
when for example it you have a different
heartbeat right now you're hurting
someone else in there and where you draw
a line again under the libertarian
philosophy you would draw a line where
you're hurting someone else and those
types of things yeah and and that's
where you you even on the question of
what you have a right to privacy before
your right to privacy doesn't extend to
what you can do to no it's a really
really loose not tied there and yeah
even Ruth Bader Ginsburg who's likely
dead admitted who does that Roby way
there's a byproduct of quote heavy
judicial intervention ISM that's what
she said
okay so I want to make sure the people
her own words yes and she's she's dead
weekend at Bernie's all over again we
can cling to this is this is more so a
generalized claim here about abortion a
lot but they have been banging on all
cylinders when it comes to this one
here's these two law specifically that
this is about regulating a woman's body
there's no law like this against men
democratic woman in the legislature
tried to fight back state senator Vivien
figures introduced an amendment to make
vasectomies a felony noting that there
are no laws regulating what a man could
do the body this creature are you to
tell me what to do with my body it's my
decision it's not yours
wait hold a second men can have learned
none in what women do with their bodies
so you want to undo Robbie wait who
weren't who is Phil in the courts
sweetheart huh you want to lose the
right to vote because she gave you that
one many of you didn't even want it duty
in the draft there by the way there are
plenty of laws like this that apply to
men
here's actually something I'm asked this
can you name me genuinely a carnival
instance where it doesn't so they
compared vasectomy right to the
heartbeat bill justice system use your
appendage it's your DNA you can do what
you want with your body justice by the
way no one out there cares about you
getting your tubes tied no one else
cares about getting the password this
was this woman leftist was tweeting and
twittering oh so now we're gonna have
laws about not about men are gonna
decide what we do with their pap smears
how often what a second how do you think
it is that none of us care about any of
those things because the vasectomy is
not ending a heartbeat by the way not
yours another heartbeat so let me ask
you this if we all acknowledge when
we're talking about a heartbeat bill
okay that you're stopping a heartbeat
and it's not the moms heartbeat the mom
doesn't have two hearts she's not a
medical marvel at least most of them
right well I with the doctor Ben
Carson's I'm gonna having to come in and
separate all of them so my question to
you is if you're ending a heartbeat
whose heart ending and can you point me
to any instance any any example where a
man can legally stop the heartbeat of
another human being innocent nonviolent
let's not get into war here came to me
any example more importantly can you
name me one example that would allow men
to do that exclusively meaning men were
allowed just men would be allowed to
stop someone else's heartbeat and women
wouldn't be that's the only way that
your argument holds water here's
something else that I that I genuinely
am curious to hear people's opinions on
because I asked my wife this the other
night women out there can you think of I
mean I'm sure women from a long time ago
can say sure because if I spoke out my
husband gave me a fresh one I understand
what right Wonder Bread era let's talk
about today can you think of any issue
today where as a woman you are told
you're not allowed to have an opinion
exclusively because you're a woman if
we're gonna say oh thought where
vasectomies men could do it well on a
second no men are not allowed to stop
another human being
heartbeat in any instance the only
people who are allowed to do that are
women it's an exception to the rule of
the only exception where it's
permissible to end another autonomous
beings heartbeat is for women so let me
ask you on the flip side are you ever
told as a woman that you cannot hold an
opinion or you are not entitled to an
opinion exclusively because you are a
woman women who are watching listen let
me know I can't think of any they're
claiming that these bills would imprison
mothers they won't these bills are
completely unprecedented they're not
these bills don't take into account the
health of the mother they do this is a
start of overturning roe v wade well not
exactly but potentially it's a
conversation we may have but let me ask
you this what if none of this matters
what if these states two people here who
are upset about these bills particularly
the Elizabeth Warren's the Kamala Harris
well the entire DNC platform there's no
there's no intellectual diversity there
at all
what if these states let's say Georgia
Alabama had passed an abortion bill okay
that made exceptions for rape and incest
and the life of the mother they already
make that exception and they banned
abortion at only 12 weeks requiring a
five-day waiting period would liberals
support it do you think they'd support
it then or do you think you guys would
protest it she and her husband did what
they thought was best for their baby
girl they got an abortion and the third
trimester reproductive rights are about
health they are about safety this is a
existential fight for the right nipple
and existential body abortion
theoretically legal it has to be
literally accessible yeah I feel like
it's a basic human right that nobody
gets to use your body without your
consent about jamming forceps anatomy
because I didn't want to become a mother
it is a normal part of women's medical
lives so far succeeding in limiting our
access to exercise our constitutional
right it's not a constitutional register
by the way but these are the same people
who don't believe in the constitutional
right to keep and bear arms which
actually is a constitutional right it's
actually spelled out we're talking about
amendments it's number two right next to
number one which includes freedom of
speech which you also don't believe in
stepping you've heard of stepping over
dollars to pick up pennies you're
stepping over rights to grab ones that
don't exist like every other speech
let's move that over here right to bear
arms I don't really like it because
David hog wasn't a Michael Moore film
14th Amendment's right to privacy
therefore you get an abortion at 32
weeks says Elizabeth Warren that's what
I'm pretty confident on like it really
is absolutely remarkable to me and by
the way I want to make sure them clear
that context of the first Elizabeth
Warren clip she was talking about
parents had a late term abortion because
the baby was going to have a congenital
I believe a heart defect yeah so I don't
want to be accused of taking out of
context here's the thing it doesn't
matter that's not why she was opposing a
20-week abortion ban you need to
understand this okay if they say hold on
a second we need exceptions on this
there's no exception for rape or incest
all right hold on a second you're
against a 20-week ban so how about on
the flip side would you only extend the
abortion beyond 20 weeks in cases of
rape incest or for example a congenital
heart defect serious birth defects the
health of the mother that's not what
Elizabeth Warren proposed no no not at
all they don't make those exceptions you
can't have it on one side of the coin
and not on the other it really is
remarkable to me when and again the
intellectual consistency
yeah-hoo-hoo who cares why should it be
rare exactly you should be able to if it
doesn't mean anything
and also the fear-mongering that really
bothered me to hear the right accused of
fear-mongering quite a bit where they're
the right fear mongers they want your
that's based on fear be honest what a
conservative fear monger on okay terror
terrorism socialism okay 9/11 Arab
Spring Isis your mongering what is it
climate change polar icecaps were
supposed to be gone by the way we're
supposed to at the entire world was
supposed to be in famine aside from
North America and parts of Europe 1111
years a Florida supposed to be gone no
more coral reef no more fish not saying
there's no climate change but the
catastrophe certainly haven't happened
right abortion if you ban abortion
you're gonna be you're gonna be jailed
for miscarrying so where is the right
fearmongers gives you a heads up based
on things that have actually happened
and are currently happening across the
world to let fear Mon there's some
things that can't be proven never happen
they move on to the next thing no one in
this country has been
regularly arrested for having abortions
or for miscarrying the if you accept
that wholesale you have bought false
fear-mongering it's not even close to
the truth and at least we can correct
that we can get to the conversation of
abortion at large hey there if you like
this video this is the part where I
would usually tell you to subscribe but
I can't do it anymore I'm going to tell
you to subscribe and then YouTube is
going to decide that we can't reach you
even though you subscribe to this
channel and then I'll say hit the
notification bell and then the
notification Bell won't even be there
anymore I don't know what to say more
than likely you'll find my face in a
milk carton but do what you can to stop
it it's just it's just it probably won't
do much